ريم بقى
سيكون نضال اكثر صعوبه هذه كانت رده الفعل
الاولى لرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
اوغلو بعد دقائق من اصدار محكمه الجزاء في
المدينه قرارا بسجنه ما يزيد على عامين
بتهمه اهانه هيئات رسميه
في الانتخابات السابقه مثيرا للجدل حيث
فاز برئاسه البلديه بعد ان اعيدت
الانتخابات في اسطنبول
قرار السجن جاء نتيجه الدعوه قضائيه ضد
امام اوغلو اتهم فيها باهانه وزير
الداخليه
وموظفين لجنه العليا للانتخابات حين وصفهم
بالحمقى
لن ارد على ذلك الشخص ولن انزل الى مستواه
لقد اساءوا الى صوره تركيا بفضيحه
انتخابات اسطنبول السابقه لن انزل الى
مستواهم كما قلت ولكنني اريد ان اصوغ
الجمله السابقه اريد ان اقول لمن نظم
انتخابات عام 2019 انتم حمقاء
الحكومه بدورها قالت ان هذا القرار ليس
السياسيه
التي يصدرونها وفق الدستور
قرار المحكمه الابتدائيه في اسطنبول
قرارات المحاكم الابتدائيه تخضع دائما
لتدقيق السلطات القضائيه في القانون هذا
القرار غير قطعيا وقابل للتقييم ايضا من
محكمه الاست في العليا
لكنها هذا التصريح لم يخفف من غضب معربه
التي شرعت بالمراهنه على انصارها في
الشارع سيكون لهذا القرار اثره على
الانتخابات المقبله بلا شك
وسيحرم امام اول وفق الدستور من المشاركه
فيها حال التصديق عليه
[تصفيق]
كان رئيس بلديه اسطنبول والذي وصفه حين
هذه الظلم لكنها تتفائل بانه سيكون سببا
في الفوز بالانتخابات كما حدث للرئيس اردن
الذي يقودون بلاده منذ عقدين عمر الحاج
الجزيره اسطنبول